je commence à me méfier des gens qui
sont trop parfaits ça sourit ses dents
blanches elle aime le chien même tout le
monde s'éclate et ouais ouais ouais on
va me croiser un petit peu et pourtant
vous êtes jaloux mais alors je vous
présente merci de me présente également
à massa
voilà qui est écrit meghan markle une
américaine qui la boude d'or voilà la
première question qu'est ce qu'elle a de
différent
cette jeune fille mais elle a tout
différent c'est à dire d'abord elle a
été choisi par la reine quelque part la
reine elle est très intelligente c'est
une femme qui est là depuis un sacré
bout de temps
et l'hiver la fin de sa vie a décidé
d'enfin vivre quelque part ce qu'elle a
toujours bien aimé ouais c'est un choix
de elizabeth and what else
laissez moi c'est moi de la mine et
savas crêper le chignon ne choisit pas
ne vous écoutent oui non ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce mariage n'aurait
jamais pu avoir lieu si elisabeth
n'avait pas dès le début donné son
accord à l'organisation de ce mariage
tel qu'il a été
c'est à dire un reconnaissance de la
communauté afro américaine nina des
particularités de mégane et de sa mère
parce qu'on oublie d'aurillac un homme
qui est sa mère n'aurait jamais pu être
fait sans la corde ou pour vous la reine
l'a choisi justement parce qu'elle
incarne et boucau pour le royaume et la
couleur je retiens que vous avez revenir
sur ce que j'ai dit son petit fils est
tombé amoureux de cette femme là voilà
si elle n'avait pas voulu dont elle
rentre dans le zèle famille est là
quelque part elle aussi choisi nam et
bien sa majorité elle l'a choisi et oui
et harry aurait puis l'épousé en disant
je renonce à mon titre de pia mère
l'aurait jamais fait ça vous n'en savez
rien chabran suis certaine gameloft a
créé à lille comme une enquête
voilà voilà jamais simple si la reine
avait dit harry dans son bureau
je n'aime pas cette petite pardon veut
dire tout ce qui est en angleterre mais
elle l est de l est de couleur elle est
américaine a mis en avant
je ne veux pas qu'elle est divorcée elle
publie épouse pour vous n'aurez pas
épouser la mort elle n'est pas
catholiques et les protestants de
l'église épiscopale à l'arrêt les choses
auxquelles vous sur le v10 vous l'époux
de la reine avait dit ariste une les
pouilles à il n'aurait pas épouser oui
parce que les liens entre harry et la
reine d'angleterre sont extrêmement je
dirais tendre autant elle était une
épouvantable mère avec ses enfants
autant elle était une grand-mère très
attentive elle a été certainement après
la mort de diana où elle a dû elle a eu
un sentiment épouvantable de culpabilité
parce qu'elle a respecté à fait respecté
ce protocole est ignoble qui est d'une
cruauté mentale de faire tenir ce petit
garçon seul de 12 ans et sans pouvoir
tenir la main de son de quelqu'un et ça
ça écrit une madame ça madame elle n'a
juste pas voulu si vous me permettez
faire un petit peu d'histoire elle là j
ai voulu attendre et comment il n'a
juste pas voulu revivre ce que son oncle
avait vécu et pourquoi elle est sur le
trône c'est à dire que son oncle avait
pas à abdiquer et ont donc on peut
décider de s'écarter de la farine est
pas
la juste elle a juste elle n'a pas voulu
que son petit fils vive puisque son
oncle a vécu c'est à dire que son oncle
avait voulu quitter roi d'angleterre
oui avait épousé une américaine divorcée
sur le trop compris mon rythme et j'ai
compris mais là c'est un peu technique à
candresse quand m on va revenir un peu
plus grand public
voilà c est ce que ces deux nouvelles
stars aujourd'hui du royaume uni est ce
que c'est vraiment la préférez la réelle
chouchou est que la reine se sert un peu
d'elle a dû tout allait rendre le
royaume du moderne elle épousait le
chouchou oui et je vous il y avait le
chouchou of honor qui me dit non c'est
pour ta génération sa mégane tulle end
mais moi d'accord elle a apporté de la
couleur dans le palais c'est ce qu'on
attendait on voit que la reine s'est
modernisée et la mariée tous les coups
excusez moi la danse et moi cette femme
est diplômé de l'université de chicago
au delà de sa couleur mais oui mais ça a
quand même d'accord avec elle a quand
même bouleversé la donne et ça quand
même vous versez les pâtes du palais
voilà qu'à l'époque les dix 10 quand
elle s'était mis avec un homme de
couleur avait fait scandale
d'ailleurs qu'elle était enceinte la
reine avait essayé de vous parler bien
fat ans non mais voilà n'ont eux-mêmes
là où par l'épaule droite n'aime pas du
tout ce côté là moi je suis qu'à la
porte de la modernité avec sa couleur et
je serai alors moi j'avais reçu ça a été
le même la presse britannique a dit un
moment et ça à lui à des missions d'un
d'un leader d'extrême droite britannique
en dix ans la couenne va te salir et
servait débat lui qu'il a une mission
des fabrications nager une question très
intéressante ne jouons pas sur les mots
ce nom il faut jouer sur la réelle aux
yeux non plus des victimes a dit m une
question est ce que vous pensez que
megan parce qu'on a vu thomas müller ou
40 elle est formidable
est-ce que megan révèle dans une
stratégie un peu dans la tête elle en
train de prendre le pouvoir
tout est calculé elle va écraser kate
qu'en fait elle dépérit calme parce
qu'en fait c'est pas voilà ce que c'est
pas ce que ça valait vraiment comme on
le pense magali je pense qu'elle a
vraiment eu un côté américain est allé
au dessus de tout ça je pense qu'elle
est juste elle même elle est naturelle
ça se voit on peut pas tricher il ya des
choses qu elle fait on peut pas tricher
ça se ressent et les gens l'aiment pour
ça justement après le côté star du
royaume
moi j'ai regardé elle a dépensé 160
12000 euros 2 pour son dressing en
quatre mois
alors que kate en a dépensé 130 milles
en un an alors ça voilà
willingham et à la bonne heure à dire
attention on parle de ça parce que donc
le prince charles qui va devenir lui le
roi un très bientôt
enfin je retirais gens qu'une info je
lui souhaite d'aller très loin à cette
dame mais c'est vrai qu'elle a un
certain âge maintenant c'est compliqué
c'est toi gbagbo président tout ça pour
toi là tout ça pour vous dire que voilà
lui a déclaré donc ça a été repris par
tous qu'elle coûtait un petit peu cher
au royaume-uni qu'elle coûtait un petit
peu cher à la royauté l'a jamais ce qui
lui fait dire à tous en même temps là
bas dit il l'a jamais dit il n'a jamais
vu ça et ils l'adorent et 17 fiches et
du tungstène
ils l'adorent au contraire et elle
contrairement à ça à ça à kate middleton
elle n'est pas obligée de règle et son
antre de régner bah écoutez je vous ne
savez on ne sait pas ce que tous ces
gens pensent
on ne sait pas ce que la panse c'est la
reine pense politiquement et c'est
depuis un an ne sais pas ils n'ont pas
le droit de laisser parler ça c'est
partout sur internet
depuis quand internet a toujours raison
ce serait
[Musique]
le ballon qu'est ce que charles pense de
mégane alors moi je suis pas dans sa
tête ni vous ni moi mais on va quand
même on a quand même quelques petits
indices je veux dire il faut quand même
savoir que cette femme dès qu'elle sort
habillé je ne sais pas si vous êtes sur
instagram
allez voir le site ce que porte meghan
markle tout est décodé tout est revendue
et dans la demi-seconde toutes les
pièces qu'elles portent sont sold out
comme et donc c'est elle rapporte
énormément d'argent d'accord et pas que
ça parce que cette femme est une femme
intelligente et ne peux pas exprimer ses
choix politiques rendant une famille
régnante
elle a trouvé un moyen quand elle prend
un sac serra saxe particuliers dont la
moitié des recettes sont revendus une
association qui vient en aide à la grèce
est ce que ces femmes intelligentes qui
arrivent à exprimer ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle dit et ceux auxquels elle croît
de manière à thé alors j'ai une question
maintenant bien ou par les opposer
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne parle que de
mégane et pas du tout de kate alors que
kate va être rude et offre jusqu'à 10
pardon jusqu'à mardi qu'elle était en
congé maternité elle a fait son
troisième enfant elle était elle avait
fait ce que je veux dire
parce que kate et william
ils sont terriblement petit bourgeois
chiant comme ils sont pas de vivre dans
leur petite maison à la campagne et ont
trois enfants
on dit que lui n'a pas envie mais seat
obligé d'avoir il sera obligé d'avoir un
moment d'être des trois d'angleterre il
n'a pas du tout envie de ça les deux
autres ils sont beaucoup plus fun ya
toujours un petit pet qui traîne de
l'alcool ils sont beaucoup plus marrant
on a envie d'y arriver à riez est vrai
qu on doit pas se marier mais il y en a
qui va du roi est l'hôte il arrive à ce
qu'il a pas le choix lui c'est
formidable et aristocrates du pognon et
a rien à [ __ ] de tes journées à
l'essai c'était un cas de sa soeur la
princesse margaret
à l'époque la soeur de la reine elle
était hyper fun elle l avait une maison
au wali moustiques
elle était elle sortait avec les qu'en
dira les rolling stones elle était
toujours défoncé c'est le sait le
syndrome deuxième mais aussi aux gens
que s'éclater ces alcools et des fonds
voilà quatrièmes c'est vrai qu'il ya
dans la presse people anglaise en ce
moment une petite lassitude concernant
le couple a raison je voyais à huy
parfait trop dormait williams était un
garçon très conservateur n'est pas drôle
du tout et ce mariage a mené non
seulement de la modalité mais de
l'humanité à cet avion royal qui en
manquait cruellement
recevez-vous l'image de la menthe cette
belle dame noire dans l'église qui était
très ému ça amène une humanité et un
petit peu web de fentes et rassembler
trois enfants de william et kate qui
compte en fait j'ai une question ana
voilà c'est la question que l'on pose un
magazine que je ne cite pas aujourd'hui
non c'est comme perrier tout à leur
personne pour le reconnaître
megan kate qui est la plus dépensière
c'est qui qui rapporte un peu d'argent
qu'on prépare les choses une autre
manière aussi un madame sais pas il
s'est tu il ya une manière de voir les
choses
des fois on juge des femmes qui sont des
femmes en vue mais uniquement à l'argent
des fringues quelques c'est vrai qu'elle
se détestent vu les caméras je déteste
mais tout arrive et les plus jeunes je
viens lui pique la vedette à me
souvienne je vous rassure tout de suite
et au royaume uni elle traîne c'est
quand même une superbe opposition et
l'autre qui ne montera jamais sur le
trône
voilà y'a pas y'a pas photo je veux dire
il faut pas tout prendre les ménages à
ces deux femmes s'est passé auront des
obligations différentes des choix
différents
elles les ont déjà maintenant sébastien
là en tant que photographe paparazzi
laquelle des deux est évidemment
intéresse le plus c'est qu'est-ce que ça
de la mégane sans aucun doute pas du
tout non eux ils sont et son trou dans
le rang tout est très libre et il n'y a
pas de fantaisie alors qu'avec les
mégane il peut se passer des choses
qu'elle donnait l'exemple qu'elle doit
donner l'exemple et kate elle doit
montrer aux britanniques qu'elle ne se
dépense pas l'argent que l'état donne à
la couronne pour pour se vêtir pour
vivre c'est pour ça qu'on dit que
l'araignée radin larané les parades 1
elle veut juste aller de ne pas donner
un mauvais exemple et kate le sait
parfaitement parce que pour son retour
justement après son congé maternité
mardi pour sa première apparition
publique à la portée des bottes canal
depuis 14 ans les mêmes c'est vrai
qu'elle recycle beaucoup elle est fière
de l'epu l'année passe du petit frère au
grand frère comme dans les familles
modernes des ferries pour vous donner
une idée je trouve que kate vous la
voulez attaquer méchamment parce que
c'est pas le même rôle c'est pas le non
seulement la même chose l es l et la
turbulente pendant menacée et qu'elle
est chiant luc fun lady di à voilà oui
mais c'est là que jamais été reine on l
a vu ses avants excusez moi ça s'est mal
terminée pour des moyens d'en finir la
chandelle
on parle beaucoup d'argent parle
beaucoup d'argent la monarchie
britannique coûte 70 centimes d'euro
anglais par anglais non non c'est
beaucoup plus dix ans les capitales
anglais ça coûte très cher la monarchie
lisa ling de calculer comme dans tout
l'est alors si on me demande combien
coûte la république française au moins
être au royaume ont fait on fait un
livre comme un sac tout à l'heure